[Music]
demi lovato you're not playing with the
children tonight i'm not playing with
the children i'm free to the winds you
look amazing do you feel you do you feel
as good as you look i feel very
comfortable these pants are very comfy
yes
and
just the pants
the shirt's very comfy too cool so did
law do this
okay first of all i love the
collaboration between you two i feel
like
he gets you you get him and he is i mean
you have been looking like
whoa oh thank you so much yeah he's
incredible to work with he's so sweet
and he's extremely talented so what is
it do you come to him and say i'm this
is how i'm feeling today and then he
just brings you stuff or do you guys
really talk about where you want to be
with in fashion and how even you're
feeling as a woman is that how it comes
we talk about all of it we talk about
what i feel comfortable in we talk about
the direction that i want to go with
fashion and how i can express myself i
love your song sorry not sorry are you
performing tonight yeah i know yeah yes
somehow maybe sorry
my mind was also yes i'm performing yeah
and how was last night singing
international anthem it was amazing it
was a dream come true yeah i'm such a
fight fan i was gonna say did you get to
stay and watch yes i did i thought we
got our money's worth yeah it definitely
it was a great fight